all right let's do this what's so fun
about She-Hulk is that there are a lot
of unexpected cameos
[Music]
I will kill for you Megan Australian oh
you are way more fun than my last lawyer
Megan's a really good actor I'm a huge
fan like it was crazy you think of this
huge star but Megan was just awesome I
am doing groundbreaking things twerking
in Marvel
and I like to think of myself as a
version of Thanos
just remember whose show this actually
is every episode introduces a crazy cast
of people there's so much more to come
in this Wacky World
[Music]
you said to my face that you never
turned into the Abomination anymore no I
said I choose not to you know these were
extenuating circumstances you understand
that this constitutes another crime and
totally destroys your chances at parole
wow
nah because I was forced
to leave my cell but I returned
of my own free will who forced you to
escape this insanely high security
prison undetected a sorcerer Supreme of
the Mystic Arts and his name is Wong
just Wong and his internet presence is a
little chaotic he's either a sorcerer
who lives in New York or a librarian who
lives in Nepal can you get to him yes
Jen it's me of course I can get to him I
sent a thirst trap it was a picture of
me with a bunch of books I just hope
that he calls back you know if blonsky's
telling the truth this guy busted him
out of his prison cell and probably
ruined my entire case